we're joined now by dr ashish jha he's
dean of brown university school of
public health
good morning to you dr jar always good
to see you
good morning gail thanks for having me
back i always wait for you to say that
we are i know it cracks me up too
let's go back to david's piece about
that booster shot
how important is a booster shot and when
do you think it will be available
yeah so first of all i don't know if we
need it i'm just really not sure gail
because the current vaccines
really do look like they're working
pretty well so i suspect that uh
we need it because of the variant though
but what they're saying we need it
because of the variant you're saying
maybe not maybe not maybe not i mean
even
the current vaccine seemed to work
pretty well against the variant you know
the jnj vaccine was tested against that
variant
worked pretty well nobody got
hospitalized or died
so first of all i don't know if we need
it if we need it
it'll probably be sometime in the fall i
suspect uh
at which point we should have enough to
for people to get it uh so we'll have to
see but i remain pretty optimistic that
we may get away without needing it at
all
we have another weapon as you know
coming out in the in this war that we
call covet the j and j vaccine johnson
and johnson
and already people are saying hmm only
one dose i don't know if that's good or
what happened to having two doses so
could you sort it out already people are
asking a lot of questions about which
vaccine is the best viser madurana j
and j one dose votes versus two what do
you say about that
yeah what i say to folks is first of all
all three vaccines are superb and let me
tell you why
look at the end of the day what do we
care about what we care about is making
sure people don't get
sick they don't get hospitalized and of
course most importantly that they don't
die
all three of these vaccines are superb
at preventing
severe severe illness and there are
minor differences otherwise
obviously jnj has the upside of one shot
only
uh and my what i'm saying to my family
is when it's your turn get any of the
three vaccines and you know don't worry
about which one get whatever is
available i got a call yesterday from
friends who are grandparents
who have both gotten their vaccines
they're ready to go
can grandparents who have been
vaccinated can they see their
grandchildren
and why do we still have to wear masks
after we get the vaccines
so do the grandparents question first a
lot of people are wondering about this
it's a really good question and look
obviously grandkids others are not
vaccinated yet
i think the way i look at this is with
the vaccinations grandparents are now
much much safer and so i think it is
much easier
what i would ideally like is for if the
outbreaks are still very large in the
community
for the infection numbers to come down a
bit more but this is the conversation
i'm having with my parents
they want to see my kids i'm not sure
they want to see me but they definitely
want to see my kids and
they you know and we're trying to figure
out when the right time is
and i think sooner rather than later
that will become safer especially as
infection numbers continue to come down
and it's important even after you get
the vaccine dr jaws you know to wear a
mask
maybe even two i even started wearing
two now because of you you still gotta
wear the mask even after you get the
vaccine
at least for a little while and the
reason is because there are a lot of
people around who are not vaccinated so
i've gotten a vaccine but my wife hasn't
and i want to make sure that if i'm out
and about if i get
infected that i don't spread it to her
so that's why i wear a mask in public to
make sure that i can keep other people
who are not vaccinated safe
at some point when everybody's
vaccinated the mass would can come off
in most instances only in rare instances
i think will we need to continue to wear
a
mask
all right dr zhao we thank you and
something tells me your parents want to
see you the numbers at brown university
of covett are way down
compared to what's happening in the
state of rhode island so kudos to you
thank you very much for joining us
this morning